thank you
[Music]
all right for those of you that have
kids this one's gonna hit you pretty
hard
but then that means we'll get a really
good opinion out of you okay what's up
not you I'll go first so
um check this out this is in Portland
right there's a dude he's drunk driving
through the streets at 90 miles an hour
it's always this he's zooming through
every red light I don't know where
you're going with this and I already
have an answer for this this is caught
on camera okay this guy's going he's a
29 year old Dupree Smith
eventually he T-Bones another car yeah
there it is which contains his family 11
year old passenger named Ryan Ambrose
that kid dies at the scene Bob look
after the arrest damn dude he got dark
yeah after the arrest it gets worse the
D.A requested that Dupree gets 100K bail
for causing this fatal accident uh the
judge however decides to immediately
release him with no bail why whatsoever
no idea for the Drug's life is this I
like to drink too no he's not a rich kid
a party so when they asked him why he
was speeding and they investigated as to
why he was zooming through the they were
in the streets and everything he said 90
miles an hour right there was a bee in
the car he was trying to get away he was
watching tickets that is scary yeah
there's B in the car holy [__] you need
to take a [__] real bad and everybody
can relate almost uh he was actually at
the funeral of his little brother where
some somebody opened fire and shot him
twice
do um so Dupree was trying to call for
an ambulance but the ambulance wasn't
arriving fast enough bleeding out oh no
he decided to drive himself to the
hospital because he thought he was going
to die but why is he drinking alcohol
yet he was already drunk from the
funeral oh people get drunk feeling it's
complicated deal with oh like coping
yeah so um so that was his only option
yeah blood he had bullet wounds so that
when he crashed have pre-existing bullet
wounds two of them exactly as he had
explained so when he crashed
yeah after he crashed the paramedics
were able to Save Dupree and they that's
when they discovered he was telling the
truth about his gunshot woman and what
answer are you looking for me
I'm so
the family of Rhine Ambrose they're
really trying to uh I mean they hate
that this happened but they hate even
more that they let him go
so they're trying to find something they
want they want this guy put in jail I
don't know about that
um well I'll say this right now dude say
it brother it's a [__] needs to
go to jail all right my son's gone
because of this [__] fruity Loop
because you don't know how to [__]
drink and drive getting shot
I call God damn
come from
Lego Vehicles you [__] some [__]
to go to jail I actually think someone
killed my kid oh my God what the [__] if
your head was off [__] you you killed my
kid that was awesome
I don't give a [__] at that point like
it's like everything stops and I'm like
bro [__] you you're losing your life
like what are you talking about no
because every so like let's say you're
you're going through a life-threatening
situation like you're bleeding out right
of course like you're thinking about
survival but at the same time every red
light that you cross you in order for
your survival you're putting at others
at risk that could kill others right so
at that point you're it's like yeah we
get it you're trying to survive but at
the same time where one of those lights
you ended up killing someone else so
then
now an innocent life died because you
wanted to risk everybody's life for your
life to be right yes exactly the judge
however doesn't see it that way the
judge
believes that uh Dupree is going to uh
follow all of the rules as far as his
like house arrest and all this other
stuff that's why he let him out without
bail uh the family is like well our kid
is dead how just because they let you
out on bail it just means that you're
still gonna get tried but you just don't
spend it in jail right up until you yeah
yeah yeah if that's the case I mean
this just happened but it is kind of a
little bit of a of uh what is it called
like it signifies
what's to come if you're let out of jail
with no bail whatsoever your chargers
probably aren't going to be super bad I
mean
and and you have an opportunity to skip
town too exactly that's another reason
that's why people like Bales because at
least keeps you inside and if they can
afford the bail they're losing a lot to
be able to like walk around at home
before due process happens and it's like
the fact the family actually said
specifically like it's not fair that we
have to deal with the loss of our boy
who's in a box and you know and he gets
to be at home watching TV yeah
yeah dude I just uh I'm on that like uh
when someone's gone they're gone forever
and you need
to be held responsible for that loss so
that's just the way it is it's accident
whatever and I'm gonna [__] it's just
you because he's gone period at the end
of the day I don't give a [__] like in
the end of the day like this person has
gone forever I'm talking about that's it
yeah and no take backs no take backs and
um actually you gotta you gotta be held
responsible for that no take backs it
was an accident sorry it was an accident
that sucks that it was an accident but
that's just that's just the way it is
there's no there's no coming back from
that and I just I can't see somebody
else walking around like everything's
okay when it's like bro that kid is gone
that family is devastating and you're
completely innocent like that's crazy
yeah I don't know I don't know I mean
would you like to hear Duprees tweet oh
God this is what he said he goes God has
a plan for me son of a [__] got shot
two times Saturday but I don't know who
all I remember is ambulance not coming
after waiting so driving to the hospital
while bleeding out I passed out fainted
from loss of blood and crashed to
another car I flew out of the car hit
the concrete tumbled about a block going
in and out of Consciousness kill the
person my baby brother protected me I
know he did I should be dead from the
crash I'm banged up pretty bad but I can
still walk and I will recover Rest in
paradise to the person who lost their
life I would never want something like
that to happen thank God I'm alive I
hate him
it's hard not to hate this guy yeah yeah
he's selfish I would have yeah if if it
was like you know what dude I would have
been like
I would have been like you know what
all that blah blah blah and in the end
would be like but I'm willing to take
the responsibility for the things that I
cause like period people start with the
loss of the kids [__] yeah
Shine the Light on me I'm super cool God
chose me to be alive because he's
stacking everything on his side there's
always moments like that when I yeah
when I think about these moments of like
if I get like an injustice like moment
like that and I'm like father I would
literally be like okay
I'll just disappear in the night
and I'll just [__] [__] show up
and just
Darkwing Duck style and just dark queen
[__] dog stuff dude it was a [__]
seasonal just sniping the whole [__]
night waiting for him to show up
one of the seats getting stuck on
[__] thing
I think he's Mexican too by the way God
don't show me a goddamn kid oh baby he's
at an Avengers event yeah that's tough
bro [__] he looks like chancho chancho
from uh Nacho Libre poor kid there's a
match again shot bro after your little
brother is [__] the funeral like that
is it's a crazy [__] situation it's
crazy too but part of me is like
thinking like he had no one to drive him
to the [__] Hospital bro but also
Imagine like killing it he was by
himself and like having the ability to
still tweet about like your [__] yeah I
hate that wouldn't you be [__] so
wrecked no you know what I mean well
some people just God loves him because
if he thinks this is part of yeah if he
thinks this is part of God's plan he
believes God took that kid's life and
kept him alive it goes both ways you
know yeah so it's like oh God wanted you
dead then I'm sorry Ryan right yeah
God's will God wanted me to be alive
yeah I hate this guy so much
God wanted you to be dying drunk and
driving but that might be like a coping
thing for him but it's still like in the
same example right if someone was let's
say like injured and rushing through the
hospital running all red lights they
kill someone I would say the same thing
it's like you were being selfish
let's say a pregnant mom was like
[__] pushing out a baby while driving
running all red lights crashed into it
maybe her and the baby survived killed
the kid same thing I would say same
exact [__] she was being selfish so no
matter who the driver is and the reasons
why they're they're saying that my
emergency is way more important than
putting others in risk or killing people
right driving at the end of the day they
should be punished for yeah which is
prioritizing their own selfishness over
the community exactly yeah which is
totally okay to like be in that mode
like if you need to save yourself like
do what you gotta yes you have to face a
consequence exactly you do something
that's all yeah exactly it's crazy
because he was
way over the blood alcohol level that's
legal address so regardless of whether
or not he had a situation where he was
shot
it's still drunk driving yeah and a
fatal Collision yeah but they didn't put
him in jail
even the D.A usually it's the D.A that
[__] that up but the D.A was even like
no put him in jail 100K bail wow and the
judge said no bail in jail he just has
to stay home straight to jail judge
ain't no one knows and he's not allowed
to go to the bar that's part of the
punishment you know those little like
tricky uh situations like what if it's
like a like a what if we make it a 50 50
type of thing like at that point you
know I mean it's like all right 50 50
right Paper Rock Scissors type of thing
like we all
parts and it's like really tough how do
you choose what if we like the judge
system because like the coin he's like
it's one of those coins with things like
you know what and wait a settle this is
still a [__] paper rock scissors and
then it would just be paper or rock yeah
yeah so
um right now Ambrose is family they
gotta go fund me set up to pay for
funeral expenses uh they said they don't
want revenge they don't want to hurt
anybody they just want him in jail where
he belongs because they said what's
gonna happen he's he's just gonna do it
again and kill somebody else yeah it
needs to be held responsible it's a
little bit of a tricky thing does it say
where he got shot
on his body yeah no there's no diagram
oh [__] well it was in California dude
because if you got huh this is in
California oh it would be [__]
California or at least sure yeah
Portland Oregon yeah Portland California
foreign